God's necessary for Morality is you said
yes okay World a a baby is thrown off a
building and God exists in that world
okay did something wrong happen yeah
great world b a baby's thrown off a
building and there's no God in that
world did something wrong happen you
throw a baby off a cliff is is wrong no
matter what okay so God yeah so God
isn't necessary for Morality then that's
seems like the quickest debunk of a
point I think I've ever had on the show
there's no world in which there are
babies if God does not exist there's no
world in which speech is intelligible if
God does not exist there's no world in
which there are podcasts that can be
understood if God does not exist there
is no reason to trust the reliability of
our faculties of reason that's the issue
but the reason it's wrong is because
there is a moral order